let's go to the phones uh you can talk
to me when we take live calls via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord
let's go to
oh i don't know how about uh let's go to
jack from indianapolis first today jack
you're on the air what's on your mind
jack from indianapolis please
uh hey david uh so
i got a couple of questions for you um
the first one would be
uh have you done any research at all
into
the way in which
music or art subcultures influence
politics
not um not as a general topic i mean
i've read and seen documentaries about
specific
musical movements for example or what
have you and its connection to politics
but not as a general topic
oh okay um yeah i just find that whole
kind of realm to be
uh fascinating personally just the way
in which
uh different genres have their own kind
of political leanings most of them are
left-wing yes there is the occasional
right-leaning
uh scene as well
country music in the us
tends to be more right-wing with
exceptions of course you know the dixie
chicks would be an exception and there's
others but country music in the us
certainly is has more of a right-wing uh
bent
yeah and even in recent years country
music has kind of started leaning more
left um you know i've heard rumors that
more of
uh the country artists in general
uh tend to be more left-leaning than
than people think interesting it's more
like kind of private for them i guess
though yeah i mean it also may be it's
private because it would be bad for
their ticket sales if it was public
yeah exactly
um but also there's i mean there's like
things like black metal and
um
uh you know like death metal uh tend to
have more kind of right leaning but like
libertarian uh ideologies versus like
you know punk rock has always been very
hard left but yep you know the
occasional right wing uh strand like
straight edge culture sometimes is right
wing i don't know
um anyway i just found that whole thing
kind of interesting
um and i guess the second question would
be
um you know you're a drummer right yes
um
where can i listen to some of your uh
playing
oh i don't know that there is any i mean
when uh at one point i was in a band
called tin fingers not ten but tin like
the tin man
and there may be videos floating around
of uh some of some of our shows that's
the only thing i can think of offhand
interesting yeah what was your like
style what do you guys play uh that was
like um alternative basically modern
alternative
oh okay yeah that's kind of cool yeah um
yeah i'll look into that yeah ten
fingers okay
all right very good thank you so much
for the call appreciate it yeah very uh
very powerful questions there one of our
sponsors today is bluechu a unique
online service delivering the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost and they're giving my audience
an entire month supply for free so if
you think you could benefit from an
extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping